a former college dean lost her job after
expressing concerns that her school was
ripping off both students and the
government Heidi Weber believed the
Minnesota based Globe University mislead
students to spend more time to get their
degrees some struggled to pay back tens
of thousands of dollars in loans in
tonight's episode of the CBS series
whistleblower Alex Ferreira
spoke with Weber about her legal battle
with the school here's a preview I saw
students being lied to
ripped off and manipulated on a daily
basis I mean if all of America could see
this wow it's unbelievable
Heidi Weber was Dean of globe
University's medical assistant program
she says the large network of Minnesota
based career training schools made empty
promises like routinely inflating job
placement rates and potential salaries
she watched as admission reps tried to
lure in students especially those
eligible for federal loan and grant
money who gets accepted everyone that
walks in the door I'm supposed to be
teaching them to save people's lives I
had students that couldn't add a two
digit number in their head and now these
students were saddled with student loans
they had to pay back right and you have
the school telling me as a teacher you
can't fail those students and it became
really apparent it's because they want
as much financial aid dollars as they
can to keep those students going you
know as long as they can when Heidi
started complaining to her supervisors
she says they ignored her and I said
this is wrong this is fraud you can't do
this
finally I went to the president way
outside my chain you're really rocking
the boat I was really rocking the boat
soon after she was fired all of a sudden
my income is gone and I didn't even do
anything wrong all I did was tell the
truth
Heidi ended up in the office of
whistleblower attorney
Clayton Hallinan he said she had a
wrongful termination case under state
whistleblower law it protects people
from retaliation after they report a
suspected violation of law and in this
case that's exactly what Heidi
she reported and then she was terminated
most whistleblower cases settled but
globe wanted to take this case to court
while awaiting trial heidi says she was
followed at night in another incident
the windows of her car were shot out in
her driveway the bullet went through the
driver's side and exited the back window
Heidi reported those incidents to police
they were never connected in any way to
Globe University it was scary it was
stressful so stressful
Alex Ferreira is with us now Alex what
is Heidi Weber doing now what happened
to her
well she's contemplating her next career
move she says she was blackballed in the
education industry and can't get a job
there so she went actually from being
the Dean of the medical assistant
program at globe back to being a medical
assistant herself and now she's she's
looking to see what her next move will
be all right Alex Ferreira will look
forward to that to me thanks so much for
having me thank you you can see the full
story tonight on the season finale of
The Whistleblower it airs at 9:00 8:00
central here on CBS